got now you have you ever fired a fire
never have you ever handled a firearm
no really you never even hand ever even
touched a real window okay but you're
not anti firearm not at all
so why living in Connecticut okay Los
Angeles Boulder Colorado I've never been
a in a conservative very and there's
been a big thing wherever I've been okay
and how do you feel about today
excitedly reminds I'm looking forward to
that I'm ready - I'm ready to purchase
looking at these than anything any one
appeal to you yeah that's to one job but
you want a larger ones I've always known
that that I was not a larger them
okay okay why I don't know I feel like
it would be easier to shoot a larger
heavier okay that's true and that that's
something that I've always it felt just
in general and everyday life heavier
things are easier to whole city right
but what about what about like to carry
to carry yeah you know I've never even
thought about okay we pick whichever
firearm and your favorite right now
grep just grab it and then that one okay
now clear it first so I first need to
clear in to make sure there's nothing in
there
there's nothing in there good but I
can't know how great break it I'll say
okay hazing even just doing that he
already has more fire are knowledge than
Nancy Pelosi always keep it aimed away
from someone you kind of end up here you
could have shot yeah okay drop the
magazine they can see there's nothing in
the magazine you're going to check to
make sure nothing around typically we
like to do one or two because you'll see
something eject okay there's nothing in
there right
grab that revolver and just clear it
check it I don't know how to how do I
open this now I don't know how do I open
up the chamber finger off the trigger
always finger off the trigger finger off
the trigger finger on the trigger plate
off the tater see you're all sugar
figure out the trigger finger off the
trigger finger off the trigger don't
give Scott a hard time because Scott
actually protects your second Amendment
right he's just a Jew from Connecticut
something like this
and see you know how to clear it check
it to make sure I have no idea
so lever-action you must have seen if
you've seen True Grit you know how these
work right I seem to regret I've seen a
lot of movies I just have no idea what
they were okay work the people who are
gun experts this isn't for you we're
just trying to show you what a lot of
people who've never been exposed with
what it's like for them and this is why
it's wonderful to take them to the range
purchase a firearm get it transferred to
them you'll see that a lot of them their
eyes are open upon entering the range as
anyone who's ever done so knows the
immediate respect for firearms and
safety became apparent our producer was
like a scared fieldmouse see if you can
figure out how to load it no clothes is
doing an infomercial there's got to be a
better way and then slider natural kid
this is the Walther PPQ model - we're
gonna put this out - seven yards someone
said seven yards it looks look further
than your other one what is seven yards
oh when someone says you know I watched
in the film he was making 50-yard hip
shot not our magazine in yep okay now
simply there you go
guards and ready to fire what was that
light thing we're off the trigger goes
off yeah
not bad at all it's actually really good
figure off the trigger yeah that's
really good its ways this is what is
aiming or hunting
coming for you shot that is not bad not
bad at all so in a self defense scenario
with typically Minyard wanting it center
body but we said yeah we'll go with the
thing gun now and we'll see how you do
so we'll put it out let's say that's
what so that way you say officer
couldn't you just show this is a bottle
way right right finally yeah that's a
carrot blade is what officer couldn't
you just shot him in the leg
go ahead no put the wrong magazine in
the wrong gun from a tree house no I
can't figure out why this is so badly
now though I can guess I'm going to go
topless top left that'll solve it my
hip-hop right hip-hop right so if you
were aiming for his leg you hit the cat
or goofing on the 7-yard is very good
for a first time threat not to embarrass
you it's just to show you the reality
with the precision instrument that's a
very good fire it's very difficult I
definitely think I need to firm up a
little bit the next time I reckon that's
what she said is totally show you here
if you come right here I just rip my fan
yeah yes
that ass though I never know yeah that
bullet is just more power
yeah that's stopping that round yeah
giving ideas that was the round that
Clint Eastwood was mocking at Dirty
Harry is 38 57 that's fine
but I uses a 44 oh good a 44 is a hand
cannon right so a lot of people have
seen the movies I mean again you see
what that power how the accurate you mix
it all I said if you want to protect
such a good set out of the sobbingly not
only ok I bet it feels good ok so your
first day shooting now she's been Lucia
you spent a couple hours in a good
couple hours and then you're like a kid
in a candy store it was pretty nice what
did kill you but you thought he was like
a kid in a school with guns what were
your thoughts more like the first time
ever shooting firearms well came in I
was very relaxed today only I picked up
the Walther PPQ the Walther the Walther
yeah and it was very good with it you're
very yeah right away talks about you're
good and I'm just now coming out of here
knowing that I've handled it for two
hours so I know what it feels like
of course I'm naughty I'm still a novice
but I can come back I can learn acne
within a short period of time I feel
like I'm comfortable right it feels it's
a good feeling but I do think this is
one of those areas which you've never
actually handle a firearm or or fired a
real firearm you're just not going to be
able to understand the scope a mate now
they're even somebody who is pro-second
amendment somebody believes in the right
to carry the scope of it means something
different to me now I still never done
it under pressure I can only imagine
what it's like under pressure you fired
the scary black rifle here baby
everything I did not not know that was
happening
well first of all you thought rifles
were going to be a lot harder it was it
was an easy gun to fire but of course
she was just
yeah it's a gun just like anything else
I can handle it yeah and be responsible
this is anyone anyone the key is
learning India and if you're fearful of
it they're going to be a pleasant
experience so are you going to be buying
fire absolutely no I'm going to find
wall
anything you're gonna buy the wall yeah
absolutely advice to people out there
who have never gone to a fireman never
actually used a firearm how's your
advice in this today you've got it
you've got to try if there's no reason
not you need to go with somebody not
just gonna before but really really
knows for doing that that was key and I
was surprised when I got here how
important the hour that expenditure
studio actually turned up anyway I need
you to race near you any good day i
watch one is going to have a leftover
lobby of the Hilton unavailable going to
be able to instruct you Amanda King of
course and even a lot of teaching people
grab my experience the community
generally build genuine people hey
sailors take another clip from the full
show Daily Show at lada with credit calm
slash mug club or it's available
exclusively 69 dollars a year that's
less than six dollars a month less than
two expensive cups of coffee or you can
feed an African child but just buy
coffee or join the mug Club Daily Show a
lot of credit calm slash mug Club see
you there don't feed children